hello and welcome to this video this is
a new 2510 game rapid game against
Smerdyakov not sure about this
pronunciation he's got a pretty decent
rating here so it's not on a mismatch he
says to Morgan good morning good to play
against a master yeah ok so we going to
see what happens it says I would be
grateful if after the game you would
give me any advice on the game yeah it
was basically given with the video so
I'm going to maybe he does not know that
I have a youtube channel so am the Kings
Indian I want to do this I mean I
usually i usually play the mac gone off
with age 3 but i recently looked at the
same ish again with the student and i
feel i should give it a go again it
really am sometimes feel it's a little
bit underestimated stops not a bear line
at all we'll see what he chooses i think
i'm currently the state of theory is
that black should go for a c5 base set
up leading to a vanilla type of
structure this would be after castles
and then next move for pc five almost
invariably what white is doing
I have a nice chat yet it didn't know
that this is going to be on YouTube but
said I should put up a good fight on
then yeah well you always should well if
some people are watching okay so we get
the mentioned benoni Bishop e3 is a good
alternative but the immediate d5 is what
I recently looked at a bit um one does
one line precisely where where I'm not
quite um knowledgeable this would be if
he now takes on d5 she takes and now a
six a fortnight h5 or night h5
immediately this strange-looking move
but this is something where I only know
that it exists and that I should
probably study it if i decide to employ
the same as you can on a more serious
level item I don't really know stuff
here I'm pretty happy if he plays Knight
bd7 or ruki aid or something like that I
think those moves can be played or white
can handle those moves without too much
specific knowledge I mean at least I
think I would manage to get something
decent out of that 9h 5 is sent very
tricky though okay went to h5 this is of
course also possible and a question here
is do i go there should be two here and
allow each form
this is definitely possible the
alternative is maybe Bishop to g5 try to
stop the age pawn from moving now like a
queen bee six could be an answer Queen
d2 night h7 this kind of this kind of
business
hmm I don't know I just don't know if I
go [ __ ] should be to h4 night everyone
this is a little bit clumsy my night is
moving quite a lot that's still well I'm
after Bishop Knight f 1 i'm basically
threatening Bishop g5 to play against
that pawn and the night has to be
rebooted anyway so okay i'm playing but
should be to him i rather should know
here what to do instead of that trying
to figure it out but the same ish is not
my main line and nowadays that's an
interesting choice if I castle I think
he's going to check me on before King
age one and then aged for my night is
suddenly trapped interesting so what do
i do Bishop e3 looks very very normal
age for night back to everyone yeah that
looks me oh I think I should do that
yeah this is always interesting black
can always insert this move and white
will almost without any particular
thought play a form hmm
it's not a move that is strictly
necessary one thing that I'm thinking
about is what is the what about this
night on g3 night to h 1 2 f2 is often
not bad so if I castle I would actually
be able to do that but I'm not sure that
I want to now be five this is shouldn't
be what shouldn't be too scared about b5
often it's not necessarily that great
because it can be attacked with a four
for example or with a three before but I
think I'm still going to do that go away
for yeah I spend a bit of time on that
because here this castle is not each one
is interesting you the usual advices as
I think Sean dafa wrote this in in his
repertoire book on 1 d4 if your opponent
goes a six and none in the modern benoni
you don't think you just play a 4 and
press the clock this is a very good
practical advice because in yeah
probably more than you know ninety
percent of the time just playing a for
would be a good choice hmm this is
surprising I think he should have played
age for tough to say I mean night f 1 2
D 2 also has its points but I'm
reasonably happy to put the night on h 1
2 F 2 it supports them center very
nicely and from F to it sometimes can go
to h3 to f1 in case of the f porn moving
black often will play h 4 + f5 in this
position or in this type of position it
looks very loosening on the King side
but black is absolutely absolutely in
need of some count to play against them
White's pawn chain if you just sits
there there's nothing this position will
be yeah quite problematic because of
lack of space and clear ideas what to
what to do actively why does a couple of
ideas I can try a long term to expand in
the center with f45 okay that's an easy
move with FYE 51 I can sometimes play on
the queenside actually playing something
like an rook could be one and then be
four okay so what's this he went f5
what's my reaction here um I can play
near just Queen d2 let's say complete my
development I don't think night f to
make so much sense he's got f4 well even
that isn't so clear but I don't really
like to like him to play at four so
Queen d2 is something that I could do
basically wait for its next move can
also take immediately on your five also
possible but Queen d2 looks very normal
if he takes Knight takes should be
should be fine sorry for the swish noise
now need a little bit of drinking for a
longer game
with f5 being played the action is
mostly going to be on the Kings side
because of them we can squares Black has
lots of pieces though on the kingside
it's not like I'm going to check made
them quickly but in general it will be
more like a king side play now blankets
not going to try some be five or
anything like that that's not going to
happen yeah what is he going to do here
interesting could you try to force
through this F phone booth with things
like Queen to f6 maybe the Queen to f6 I
will probably take on f5 mmm very very
difficult position when I was still
playing the Kings Indian with black I
played them other setups against the
sameish up like knight c6 and a six
quite often and sometimes a six yeah
this is a move that I was thinking could
be it could be quite interesting because
midnight is on edge one here the night
on f2 already i mean i can just take
this yeah g3 yeah it's not a move that
I'm so happy with letting this some pawn
live never taking taking looks very
it's not clear though we can probably
take you for plain 95 i think i'm going
to play g3 not totally happy with it as
i mentioned but the alternative seems
worse
and could have done something different
there right h 1f 522 h 3 mm well 22,000
sell for ideas on 22 seemed almost
mandatory yeah well anyway I'm not sure
that this is bad I'm just not so happy
with with this what is he going to do
maybe just Knight to e5
or take on e4 and then Knight to e5 if
it takes on before i'm going to take
with the night pawn takes pawn takes e4
some white gets black the c5 square
forever and ever don't think that I want
that nobody this looks this looks very
okay for black here somehow I wanna
maybe I should have taken the point it's
always trickier to have such a pawn on
on age 3m in your camp any invasion
would be a very dangerous the Queen
coming into whites position or look very
very deep in the game and not saying it
it will happen in the next couple of
moves but very much later in the game
could be could be quite a problem that
there is a spawn okay so if he takes on
e4 I already wonder maybe maybe I should
actually take with the pawn to speed up
my development here with the Deaf had
opened if F takes 90 x 90 5 i'm not
quite sure what i'm playing them don't
even go night f2
well he has some other alternatives of
course instead of taking on your form he
as various keeping the tension moves but
if he plays that same Queen to e7
something like lab then night f2 and
enables me to recapture on e4 if he
takes later with the F night so I think
if he wants to check only for you should
probably do that now yeah I wonder if
context does actually make some sense
because of a better a better development
I don't think so
so we immediately placed the smooth okay
that cannot be completely bad or
anything so what now I think 9 f 2 looks
very logical being able to take on e for
the night I can also take on f5 this is
actually making quite some sense yeah
why not actually this isn't that good
action a tickets Bishop takes Knight f2
I can always do that right it takes it
okay
and now we capture sir when you thought
if you wanted to do that you should have
done that when I had to take with the
scene I'd but ok it's not something that
I'm super sure about
I have to say that I'm always a little
bit skeptical about the type of position
like black hassium simply because he has
weakened just King position so much
long-term you know with the pawns being
advanced and so on I mean he has lots of
pieces around its own it's not something
that can be punished quickly but I'm
always kind of skeptical about that at
least from a purely objective point of
view in a practical game um things are
always a little bit more yeah I'd say
less straightforward activity
compensates for for for a lot here i
have a structural weaknesses so what
happens here Bishop h6 is a possibility
sometimes here trading off his fee and
cattle bishop which is a good defender
of the king one thing however is is
quite clear it's all about concrete
moves in the skin and I'm curious what
is going to play
one thing is if he tries you should f5
in this position I might go g4 and
encourage him to trade because if it
takes then my night only four will be
excellent and in terms if he challenges
is this was Knight f6 I have 95 to e6
this kind of thing we should have 5g
form Bishop takes e4 and weakens the
light squares a lot okay so why am I not
able to take on d6 why is that
impossible
hmm I kind of refuse to believe that he
just blended this pawn but what is the
point
hmm I don't see it I have to say I don't
see it
96 I mean what what is there with 96 I'm
simply yeah me I taking be seven so I
mean he has to do something really
quickly there is no way of mini can
attack the night with Queen to be six
but I just go back to your form and I
don't see it between f6 doesn't work
Queenie 7 i'm going back there is no
tactic only for sorry i don't get it i
think i can just take it what is the
deal
you
after being quite cautious enough
tactics because black has some active
pieces mostly the 995 so those been only
types of position they are notoriously
tricky so I simply didn't see why I
couldn't take it it's also I mean a
threatening light p7 night xe5 very very
strongly so it's not like you can play
any moment play a poem down it's also
the whole structure crumbles
you
he also doesn't have any useful
discovery with the bishop again as night
b7 comes with tempo and then i take c 5
next move okay so here
okay I cannot like take on b5 a couple
of times that that wouldn't work but I
can play I mean if I take that as f3
hang but I still have night be seven and
this looks quite annoying because night
xe5 is so strong yeah okay this is
problem probably strong
yeah i'm just going to see 50 k 95 p.m.
in case of be 4i have like three to e4
yeah it looks like two pounds basically
ok so here I have to take I guess yeah
okay I have to take
any trickery going on here my yes to
recapture I can definitely i can
investigate d6 after that and if wonder
about the time spent here push-ups III
the only intermediate move that i can
see and it it should work cause of d6
you
yeah so here I can definitely go with
these six d6 Quincy six this is going to
be good but so wonder if its best Bishop
defoors also a move that is probably
going to be quite strong let's trade the
bishop Queen to deform it looks quite
convincing from a technical point of
view d six Queens is six ok I can take
on the seven check em it's not bad but I
think this is strong just trade this if
this is only active p so trade this get
the Queen to d4 and then yeah continue
to play in the center while being two
pawns up so I think this is a good good
decision I can always also just take on
1d seven in case of yeah if I don't
really see anything better after move
like rook c8 or so there is probably
something better yeah he's correct dates
as good lord I messed it up few moves
after the end of my opening theory
shameful I think you're probably going
to going to resign Sioux Nation and I so
plays and move them so okay that take g7
now he's can take it with check but I
have Bishop b4 bag so this is going to
be alright
okay take that and now how to how to do
this rook ae1 maybe 496 I'll push the
deep on okay this is a useful move okay
I guess these six yep let's use this
pawn it also allows 25 or 95 depending
on circumstances well I wanted to say I
can take it but maybe not so I have to
be a little bit very here so I'm not
stumbling into some some stupid trick
however if i take it here like okay
rookie a droopy 87 route 28 Queen takes
g5 Queen default check king age 1 i'm
attacking this rook it should it should
work
can also play No ok d7 new tricks on you
want some okay let's do it you're still
I mean I know it sounds kind of weird
but you still have to be kind of
observant here because the king is is in
a tricky spot e with the porn on h3 you
can really quite easily um screw
something up here so d7 and I was
thinking look at the 18 g5 as we call
that a decision yeah so he resided
challenge no it's a very challenging me
okay I cannot take this right now
because of the the video I'm happy to
give him a rematch of course okay so
let's have a recap of of this game we
had the same as kings in yin and one
thing that I mentioned and a line that i
think is quite interesting as black
going for for this idea it looks very
strange because of the pawn structure
but the point is that black will get
this f5 and very very quickly and his
activity is very very good yeah we have
to note that white has spent a lot of
time on on pawn moves night moves sanity
has not cancelled yet so this is
something for black to investigate age 5
is I think one of the traditional main
lines I played here and he played nine
th seven yeah h4 was possible then I'm
going to go here and the night sometimes
has a good way of renewing itself of
course it has spent lots of time but
black with the age porn also has changed
his position in a way that is not just
positive
so silly silly it's okay probably for
black to do it now at age seven I think
there should be three make sense it's
important to see that I cannot castle
here because of the check check yeah
like he I'm blundering a full night
interesting is by the way I have the
engine on here and it says rook f2 or
could be interesting yeah it's funny
yeah what what the engines nowadays
evaluating stockfish check evaluates
this position as just slightly better
for black here minus 0.4 of course only
after a couple of seconds of calculation
but but still yeah it's an exchange and
the engine basically acknowledges that
the fianchetto bishop is very where it's
very important if we black case still
that's probably a somewhat we had at the
end now a six was played and when day
for I was thinking about this for a
moment because I felt that it's quite
nice and i can get denied we routed here
might be 59 f 2 I don't think this is
particularly bad for me so it's an
alternative you can often play in this
kind of fashion to attack this bone
structure but ok for is the conventional
decision and he went 97 yeah this is the
alternative again where I'm getting the
night over here can debate about that
that's better for widen comparison or
not I always think that those positions
are on at least the reasonably and murky
yeah I mean you just this kind of thing
maybe why does better I mean but this is
a very very complicated and active
position for black so I wouldn't be sure
at all what to make of it so we had 90
several castles h4 i know i could go
here and he went f5 yeah the thing is i
went here and then aged 3 was was coming
that didn't like it so much it's so
interesting to consider this because i'm
not entirely sure how good
for actually is the thing is this is of
course securing the e5 square for black
but on the other hand the King side is
going to be totally closed the pawn
chain here is very very solid now and
why it still has ideas on the queenside
with sorry I was wrong arrow with a
later before so even though something
like this might happen here with black
having nice looking pieces I'm still not
sure probably why this just better with
9 a-4 would be one before and something
like g5 for example if he does that I'm
just going to and well here maybe night
to g3 yeah well g5 is not threatening
anything to be honest so it's a pretty
bad move yeah well 94 before I'm going
to get this in I think this is quite
okay for white so maybe not f2 was a
good alternative Queen d2 and now I
thought here you should take immediately
and not allow me to play night f2 so
that i can take on e4 with the F night
so this immediately I think I don't like
that so much this gives him the
fantastic square there on e5 so I would
if I'm sorry I would have taken with the
night I guess and now something like 95
this is what I am expected to happen
yeah and now I got this in the game very
quickly yeah and now I'm he played night
sorry Bishop d7 which was basically
blundering the d6 pawn yeah i'm not sure
what he should do i was thinking a move
that i considered was Bishop f5
developing this piece but i don't know
how effective that is even g-form comes
into consideration this is something
that i was some thinking about during
the game if he takes it and I take
my night is going to be quite strong
there you cannot do this amp this this
is this thing coming but maybe Queenie
sell it was probably not a terrible
position so Bishop f5 I can also
consider this and maybe later g4 yeah
it's a very typically complicated benoni
style kind of game so Bishop d7 and then
I took it I'm sorry very nice Elna this
is also making quite some sense get the
Queen developed what is good here with
this all the all those things happening
on the King side and what I'm not going
to play like rupee one before which is
sometimes possible at the center is
stable and close I think probably look a
to you one look I'm messing everything
that there is on the on the on the King
side in the center chair very
complicated this might go here don't
know if that is a good idea you can
still do this of course maybe just drop
back it's very tough but this is
probably how it should be played and
here I'm after 96 it's basically game
over it's a porn just by a material that
also the position is crumbling
completely can something like this is
for example falling apart very quickly
yeah try this yeah engine wants to take
on c5 immediately but this is certainly
also good grabbing a second porn having
d6 also yeah 94 is going to be taken and
now we are there are a couple of options
d 6 is certainly also okay but we should
be four is quite logical yeah you
if you can trade off the best piece that
the opponent has it's usually a good
idea so here and it took this taking
here doesn't help I'm going back and
have a fantastic bishop so this and
centralized this rook yeah he always had
this by the way but it doesn't really
matter much i can go queen bee for like
like this for example okay wookie aids
and now I went with G 695 y and this is
ending the game if he goes rook the
eight again oops sorry rook e8 I can
actually just take jazz just one check
and it doesn't continue but always be
careful if you have such a pawn in your
cam there are always some kind of some
kind of ideas for for the black play
antum can easily be a be tricked you
have a TM nothing nothing much happened
to have to be sexy he only has one check
and then things clarify so basically it
was a night XD 630 that he just missed
them yeah probably and maybe it didn't
help that I told him that his own video
but the way he asked me what about the
game yeah I had to tell him basically
okay hope you enjoyed this video thanks
for watching